hi everyone my name is Olga Petrova and
I am a researcher at Avast for almost
two years now and this is my colleague
Eureka simav hi i'm yuda Cosima and I'm
also research at a vast our talk will be
more on a technical side of spectrum
with a little bit of machine learning
here and there so let's start our goal
today is to show you how we leverage AI
and Big Data to burn malware and to
start a fire you need a spark so first
present the first part of presentation
will be held by me and I will describe
the malware research it's the part what
I'm working on I'm focusing on the
second part will be taken by Yuri and he
will talk about anomaly detection and
he's also prepared a cool demo for you
but first of all we would like to thank
our big data system team in Prague and
home researchers and engineers which
contributed to to this work and last but
not the least threat researchers and
analysts without whom our work wouldn't
be possible or even wouldn't exist Avast
is dedicated to creating a world that
provides safety and privacy for all no
matter who you are where you are or how
you connect this is the main motor of
our company we are consumer oriented and
we have a large user base we have more
than 400 million users majority of them
are using our antivirus on PC or Mac and
the rest are using our mobile solutions
and each month Avast prevents around 1.5
billion malware attacks it blocks more
than 5 500 million visits to malicious
websites and we collect and analyse 8
million samples
and for this we are using 3-step threat
approach so first step is to identify
thread the thread might be in a form of
executable file on Windows or it can be
also some website official website
second step is to block it we for
executables for files we usually deploy
our definition virus definitions to our
client and by this we are blocking the
files on our client systems and the
third step is what we are doing with URI
is our day day to day job we are
analyzing and automating the first and
second step and arc I'm going to talk
about malware classification so since
the beginning of a vast history we were
collecting and storing all executables
for executable files on our internal
servers and as you can imagine it is a
lot of data actually more than 700
terabytes of data to classify them with
classical machine learning methods we
use a principle of divide and conquer
we are clustering we are extracting
first static features from our samples
from binary files and by static I mean
we are extracting features without
executing this file so for example names
of sections some flexin header something
like this so it can be binary or float
features then we cluster these files
with the simplest possible algorithm
k-means and for each cluster we train a
random forest classifier just to
summarize the problem we have we have
more than 500 handcrafted features from
our thread researchers experts our task
is to classify files to clean malware or
potentially unwanted
program categories and as I mentioned we
use two-step pipeline cluster and then
train render forest classifier this on
the on the left side you can see an
animation of Disney visualization of our
clusters and as you can see we have a
lot of clusters are homogeneous they
contain only malicious samples the red
ones some of clusters contain only clean
files the green ones but as data analyst
or machine learning researcher we were
always interested in origins of our
datum so on the right side you can see a
u map visualization of small amount of
data we have the static feature space we
were interested in things like SK means
even suitable for our data of course not
what is what is the best clustering what
hyper parameters to choose and for this
I was always using spark and during this
journey I came into realization that I
needed to really implement the whole
pipeline in spark but first I would like
to mention the the architecture of our
spark cluster so we have a bunch of
servers which which construct our spark
cluster client send us events and we
stream them through Kafka then we can
stream them further to actual consumers
we can save them to HDFS we can perform
elasticsearch on the top of the data and
we can calculate different metrics and
what-what have been done so in the
beginning of pipeline we have this huge
amount of data stored on servers we
extract features perform clustering
and then do training I've utilized the
feature extraction step and the rest
were just several lines of code in spark
as you can imagine I didn't mention the
the biggest problem so we had this this
top part this was our old system and was
super performant it was tailor-made
solution which were which was patented
by our software engineers it was
optimized but for me it was impossible
to perform any experiments because any
change would require me to write and
test code in C++ and any change would
take months so now real world problems
unlike our tailor-made k-means plane
planned implementation of Sparky means
outputted 20 mega clusters with more
than million samples in each and of
course these clusters did not fit into
memory so low-hanging fruits we try to
adjust worker memory of course in spark
adjust course per executor but if you
can allow yourself you can easily use
the most simple trick and sub sample
data which we were which we were doing
essentially after and I would like also
to mention how we use spark with with
Python in our validation production
feedback loop because when we train
models we cannot just simply push them
into production we actually need to
track the performance of these models
and deploy only those which have the
higher the highest accuracy and this is
a schema of our validation production
pipeline so first when we train our
models we deploy them into silent mode
and track their responses and we don't
actually
anything to our clients we store them to
HDFS and as soon as we have some data we
can we can compute performance metrics
and output some graphs and we we
actually kind of stick to our
handcrafted solution when we output
graphs in PNG format from MATLAB play
matplotlib
or we also utilized possibility to have
interactive graphs from portly and this
web and this graphs are served on a
simple flask web flat based web page
just to summarize what we had we had a
optimized and performant
system any change and experiment would
take us months to develop and it was not
good and we ended up implementing this
pipeline in parallel in spark it is
slower but it's much easier to
experiment with and allow us to ship
fast changes so URI is gonna to take the
second part thank you I'm going to talk
about anomaly detection time cities so
how do we get malware to time series yes
as my colleague mentioned to be deploy
definitions of files to clients and when
some definition is triggered it means
some this some malicious file and when
the file is detected with the
application sends a report back to our
back-end saying I detected this malware
is this name from this family and we
have thousands of detections per minute
I would like to show small video let's
hope
so this is the map of our honey pots
this just computed switch somewhere all
over the globe and this map shows how
these honey pots are contacted by things
which are not supposed to contact honey
pots and you can see that there are a
lot of different things happening all
over the globe and it's impossible for
analysts to actually analyze it manually
without so many reports so many things
have happening so how can we help
analysts to analyze a new emerging
threat on you malware campaigns we
decided to try anomaly detection on time
series when we get reports we gotta buy
them by detection name and time window
and we create time City which is
depicted here it's just for one
detection each point is says we detected
this malware using this time window so
many times and this time is normalized
but we can have 60,000 of detections 15
minutes and our goal is to say okay that
is here and here please take a look
check it and our approach is the
following we take input the input
machine learning model is actual time
City the blue line here and machine
learning model generates predictions
it's the red curve then we assume that
that is a sudden change in time City the
model will not be able to adjust fast to
it and the difference between
the prediction and real value will be
much larger than average and we mark
this residuals which are larger than
normal as an anomaly the problem is that
we have thousands of different
detections
we cannot do it with just one machine
generic model we need basically one lsdm
per each time city so our first idea was
to create a custom streaming app as
supportive of concept we went with
peyten because it has nice machine
learning frameworks and it's easy to
coordinate but the big big part of the
this beautiful concept of this
application was solving actually editing
data from Kafka aggregating
checkpointing and stuff that actually
solved by some applications it was
written by the searchers including me
and it was working quite well but it was
not ready for production we are not sure
if it would be working stable over the
long period of time and also it's
difficult to experiment with in this
code it's it was quite a large amount of
code and also it's not scalable yes we
did it for 200 time series but we have
thousands it's difficult to scale so we
united with our engineers and we started
to look for outer heaven and we found
particle streaming it's not exactly
heaven but it's very nice working API
which is clean and quite easy to use so
I would like to describe some advantages
of spark streaming which we found using
our experimentations
the first advantage is unified
processing engine and this is huge
feature for us because spark streaming
was designed with the goal to unify
streaming and batch processing it
basically can build a bridge between
research department and engineering
engineers can build the pipeline's
getting data from Kafka and the
department can work on creating models
creating anomaly detectors and then we
just put blocks together and it works
second advantage is the time windows
work out of the box for us it was huge
we bought Chris time cities we need time
windows and we can just specify interval
of which we want for our models and our
models get only this amount of data also
spark has built-in water marking which
is used to deal with late data so client
sends a report but for some reason that
is huge latency and it arrives much
later and spark can just deal with it
and it can assign it to the window it
belongs to or discarded the second the
third advantage is end-to-end pipeline
so when we work with big data it's very
expensive to the compute results we need
to and we want to send the results to
researchers to some further processing
and we want to send it to analysts to
report the design some anomaly and we
want to send it to some visualization to
have some nice graphs and spark also
allows us to do it
and the last but not least is resilience
dreams spark allows us to define a
checkpoint directive and it takes care
of saving batch IDs offsets and if for
some reason our application fails we
have a checkpoint we can start from it
and we don't know to recompute anything
so after we changed from pure Python 2
pi spark it was nice to see how more
readable is our code so on the left is
other code before and you cannot read it
it's a large amount of code it's very
difficult to understand what's happening
and this is how it looks in spark and
you just read data from Kafka you could
buy detection name and window you count
acute ences of some malware then you
apply the Machine generic models
generate predictions then you apply
anomaly detection and flash results to
something another advantage of spark is
it allows parallel training we have
thousands of models that they are not
deep models we can train them on CPU but
if we do it sequentially it will take
large amount of time and if you just
distribute your training jobs to
different workers you can have hundreds
of models at the same time also spark
was quite nice to work with but there
are some challenges one of them is an
expected behavior so for example when I
was doing some experiments on my machine
it was not working now
that's nothing just empty output and
same code on my colleague machine was
providing results which we expected and
we are still investigating why it
happens because there is no any nothing
can locks nothing in no exceptions so
this and silent favors quite big
problems for us so I would like to show
how it looks like
other than the code before and the
output can be in this case output it it
to console and it's just protection name
some date predicted value actual value
and if it's anomaly or not and the code
to do that looks like this so it's
almost same thing which I showed in the
slide with some additions such as
watermarking and we also add models
which we trained before and save to perk
a file but for example you want to read
from Parker file so you can easily this
is how you did from Parker file and this
is how you did from Kafka you can very
easily switch between these two two
options and you don't need to hide a lot
of code ok so the takeaways actual
streaming allows very easy collaboration
between science and engineering teams it
was very easy to collaborate with other
engineers job he was writing one part I
was
doing different parts at the same time
very easy it's very nice tool box to do
anomaly detection in real-time on time
cities a lot of built-in features and it
allows very good parallelism on when
training the models thank you and if you
have any questions we answer any
question no okay do we really need
antivirus on Mac that was the question
yeah I have one because it was brain
stolen my machine but actually I think I
think yes Mac is still targeted can you
provide some details or or examples you
you met during your work on Mac threat
yeah exactly
well to be honest I work with mostly
with the Windows executables so this is
probably our main focus I cannot think
of any threat but I can imagine that
some ransomware can easily can easily
run on Mac and for this you need an
anti-virus to block it thank you next
question
yeah I understood that with the Apache
spark please speak louder it will do you
know so I read that with Apache spark it
was little slower so so could you please
like experian model more detailed like
the environment on which the spark is
running and is it in cloud or know the
specifications and what were your sample
size and you said like you again
deducted the sample size so I would be
more interested in like the
configuration the runtime environment
for the spark
okay thousand course on our cluster and
amount of data was 450 million samples
and the deal is that on our tailor-made
a k-means we have used it is it is well
distributed so I think well distributed
so when when you when you are doing
something on spark you partition your
data and actually it may became slower
when you partitioned them incorrectly
and the latency from communication
between workers can affect I think this
was main reason and other reason is that
our so the thing is that only k-means
part was was slower the random force
training was actually faster because we
used this paralyzed pandas UDF training
k-means I believe it was it was
optimized several times by our by our
software engineers and that's that's why
it that's why it was okay
question okay I can see any questions
thank you
[Applause]